how do you define woke there's a lot of
things I mean you want to start with
biological boys playing in girls sports
that's one thing the fact that we have
gender pronoun classes in the military
now I mean all of these things that are
pushing what a small minority want on
the majority of Americans it's too much
it's too much I mean the idea that we
have biological boys playing in girls
Sports it is the women's issue of our
time now she's not certainly not
defining it she's giving examples of
things she believes are woke it's sort
of like if I said hey can you define
what a fruit is and you go well you know
you've got your banana you've got your
cantaloupe right but what's the
definition of fruit and we would say oh
well the fruit is the seed bearing
structure in a flowering plant formed
from the ovary after flowering now it's
true that sometimes examples might be
more illustrative than some kind of
definition but these are the people who
say if you can't Define woman there's
something wrong with you